my picks
um for
UFC 280
will be Sean Brady Muhammad you know I
[ __ ] love you uh Sean Brady Philly's
Finest it's tough to pick against him
the Eagles right now so I'm just going
based off the Eagles doing their damn
thing and Sean Brady such a Savage he's
been my Underdog Dark Horse in the
welterweight division he's gonna be
fight for a title next year I guarantee
you I take Sean Brady via submission I
will take uh I hate this Darius I'll
take gamrod
I'll take game right for your decision
I'll take sugar Shawn O'Malley
I'll take TJ dillashall and Charles
Oliveira Charles levere by finish I
don't know what round
I have no idea when he pulls it off I
think he's gonna be down on the
scorecards and pull it off he's gonna
have to walk through some [ __ ] tough
tough fire to pull this off but 25
minutes most dangerous guy to ever do it
knees elbows submissions punches kicks
I'll take my chance of Charles Oliveira
I think Charles Glover gets it done via
decision that'd be my bad [ __ ] parlay
Charles wins via you know finish
um if he goes to judges it's Islam by
landslide
uh like I said Charles decision I'm
sorry Charles finish uh under five
rounds TJ dillashall I'll probably say
via finish five rounds I think DJ
finished Al Jermaine
um sugar Shawn
best bet would be decision I could see
him get a finish with a knee or
something because he does have the reach
and perion I think is going to
incorporate wrestling wrestling and then
game rap the decision Sean Brady via
submission those are my pictures 280
that was [ __ ] tough to pick tough
card great card such good card like I
told you guys earlier we're doing uh I
want to call it calabas fight command
but it's nowhere near Calabasas we
should call it the Mormon companion it's
uh the Salt Lake City fight companion
and that will be with me and Frank mayor
plus some other gas that is live 11 A.M
mountain time that will be 12 uh Pacific
Time live on thick boy YouTube come
watch this amazing card with me
see my grand old time me and Frank are
some chatty Kathy's 11 Pacific right 11
yeah my bad 11 A.M Pacific time that
would be 12 mountain time okay
which is Mormon time
enjoy the fights man I'm in this guide
for a fight top to bottom in a hot
[ __ ] second stack